what does social media have to do with
the conversation so I find that social
media has a major thing to do with the
conversation in terms of dating because
expectations are set so high I think
it's I think people expect I think it
raises women's expectations more than
prices men's I think it raises
because women's are DMS are flooded they
are very true yeah and so it gases
women's up women up and think they're
hotter than they are because they can
get you can be an average chicken of an
NBA player slide into your DMs it kills
your confidence
don't get me wrong I I don't think it's
great either way so I do think there's
an issue in terms of it it sets
expectations to be higher and then when
you have so much access to speaking to
you know hundreds of women on a daily
basis men also become more picky
it's a small it's a it's a small
percentage of men that are picky because
again
and that's what I'm saying you're right
it is harder to get the small percentage
of guys to commit
because if you find this guy attractive
a lot of other women probably do too why
would he commit when he can just bang a
bunch of chicks let's put all the 20 on
an island somewhere and we'll all live
happier you would go to the
Islanders
what is the exact time and location
I'm a good swimmer you want to go to
that and only that if you take away the
20 of the guys and put them on the
island then there'll be a new 20 of guys
that you are not interested in exactly
let everyone get a chance man yeah so
you you always want the top you can't
settle settle
settle for what you like it's like lower
your expectations lower your
expectations I don't think that's that's
I don't think that's a hot take but
what go ahead I don't think it's a hot
take to so so I guess my opinion on this
is a bit more nuanced than that yes
everyone has you know expectations that
can vary and sometimes they can be a bit
ridiculous so but I don't think that's a
bad thing I actually actually enjoy the
hustle and I don't think it's a hot take
to tell women that hey you should you
should settle for less you should settle
for the average xyzer I think it's your
job as a man to be that that top person
you're either a beta or you're a
successful man inside inside of this in
the dating game because only a man
that's winning will say that
look I will tell you I'm not necessarily
winning I could be doing better but you
know and I I think I'm far from a beta I
just that's just my my nature
no see you so you're winning then
because you're in the higher perspective
you're in a smaller percentage of men
that's actually been sexually I do quite
well right there you go
no wait wait it doesn't it doesn't favor
you to change it maybe like 50. but I
think it's it's more about like the
attitude though I think it's more like
because when you when when I say I do
quite well that I probably go out more
than you I probably put in more time and
energy into understanding the game than
you probably had more experiences that
have affected my dating experience you
know these people so people act like you
know it just happens it takes work and
I'm gonna keep working on it you're
right there is a group there is a group
of men that like are addicted to Corn
right they just play video games they're
not working on themselves and they have
bad results and you don't really feel
bad for them for having bad results but
on the other hand you have women that
are super overweight asking for a guy
that makes six figures and like you
don't see that type of male delusion
wow well you actually do see some of
that because I know I know a lot of
gamer boys with very poor social skills
that think they're entitled to you know
top shelf women but being real do you
really feel like it's at the same rate I
mean it's processed differently that
that guy gets shut down it's
embarrassing yeah that's what I'm saying
like like men are faced with reality
quick yeah women aren't because we lie
to each other that guy's not happy yeah
and then we and then we have movements
like you know [ __ ] shaming right fat
phobic we have all these movements to
like cushion us yeah and don't get it
twisted I have my frustrations with
women as well like I think in a casual
dating game there is definitely
um expectations are quite high and I
think personally a lot of women don't
understand how to have a healthy casual
relationship I think people mix up with
very sentimental sentimentality and
that's why they get played by the same
guys because these guys know you want a
connection you're saying you're a big
girl but you know when they mess with me
they're like oh why aren't you texting
me at night because we're a college
relationship I'm not gonna kiss you good
night you can have a healthy casual
relationship that's that's my view yeah
and I've yeah
it just takes majority you just have to
be transparent be transparent be mature
um yeah you're not playing on fire
I don't think women are biologically
predispositioned for it like
statistically they're not they're not
and and I think as a guy you're like
yeah you can have a healthy casual
relationship because that's a man's
point of view and some and some girls
can do it but like in my experience
typically like they've just had a bunch
of sex to the point they don't care
anymore in my experience every time we
orgasm you fall in love with this guy so
the Casual relationship
not not every time I'm saying early on
so so girls typically Bond more with the
first couple of guys they slept with
yeah okay and and so and they tend to do
that through orgasm yeah
in my experience though that the women
who tend to be able to be able to do
this or they tend to be older they tend
to be like over 27 yeah they don't
necessarily have a high body count but
they're normally very educated they have
that pendant they have their own lives
so my my ideal woman is actually what a
lot of people would say is the woman
that will give them the most stress
because these guys say oh well this
woman thinks she won the show yeah you
can run the show I'll see you once every
two weeks what am I fussing about or you
know women who are still in love with
some other dude cool you can see him in
the two weeks I'm not seeing you you
know and and if you think like that
that's called frame though because I
have nothing to prove and when we want
to escalate the relationship then there
are a lot of ways that you can build
closeness but I'm just I'm just someone
where I know what what when what I'm
doing is building a more intimate
relationship than our relationship is
actually at so you're a sad guy no I'm
the main guy actually no in terms of
like if she's got a husband a partner
and you see you see her in between the
relationships you're like the side guys
no she this is not married women this is
just women who are around maybe they may
be seeing multiple guys I don't ask
because I don't care because so you're
winning in the game then casual
relationship in the Casual game but it's
a mindset though that's the thing I'm
asking if it's I'm saying are you
winning yes or no I do all right so
wouldn't it wouldn't it be like
um bad for you if the game was to change
and women to stop having casual sex with
you counterproductive would not be
counterproductive if woman was to stop
having casual sex yes
I guess so right so you're not right so
you're not you're not advised to give um
advice the right advice because because
you're telling girls to sleep around
benefit to you exactly yeah but it can
also benefit them as well
what is the what is the most conducive
to building families uh stable emotional
relationship yeah yeah and so like
that's why you see 50 of women over 30
being single and childless and then you
have the least happy group of women are
45 that make over 50 000 per year that's
the least happy group of women so casual
relationships leave women unhappy in the
long term if they don't have a family
yeah but that also depends on the
mentality of the people around them the
men at the time so a woman you can
consider quite Pious now you could go
back 10 years and she's now someone
who's acting completely wildling out oh
yeah part of it is like the birth is
society you're in birth control change
dating forever yeah like that in a way
you can't go back absolutely but yeah I
personally I don't think casual sex is
is the worst thing but it has to be
approached with care it's not something
you do carelessly this idea that yeah I
just sleep around check whoever you want
whatever is is the reason that a lot of
these girls out here getting played and
Crossing two things casual and intimate
and they don't even know but I know that
okay I'm gonna